Now, the next market type is a new market. Customers don't exist today.
As the real questions are, if they don't exist, how will they find out about you?
And how will they even become aware that they need to be in this new market?
And by the way, how do you know the market size of something that doesn't even exist today?
The market size is zero and what factors should you create that the industry has never offered.
Now, a way to look at this is take a look at the chasm.
Man, this is scary. That is you can sell to the crazy people all you want.
The early evangelists, the early adopters, and that's nice but you'll have a small business
until you figure out how do we get the masses to adopt?
and here's what that hockey stick sales curve looks like.
Here are the early people you're selling to and one of the mistakes
that start-ups and entrepreneurs and founders make, is look at that slope of those early sales,
and when you get them, you go great time to like kick up spending
and look at this, our board is happy and when we start doing advertising
and stepping up the company, but then it kind of declines
and people scratch their heads on what's going on.
What's going on is the mainstream market just hasn't adopted and this might go on for years
and never kick in but if you're lucky, you'll hit a tipping point and market adoption happens.
And when it happens, it happens faster than you could imagine
but at times, it takes longer to get there than you could imagine.
So in a new market, one of the things you need to be thinking about is that,
is there any possible way to move this curve in?
There's a couple of really interesting things to notice about in a new market.
One is this value of debt of almost no sales can continue for years.
Now, why is this important to know?
Well, just imagine  you're a start-up and you put together a nice financial forecast
for your board and your investors and they all believe that you are an existing market.
So, they're expecting you to have revenue that increases every year.
Why? Because you've never asked the question what type of market am I in?
Now, if you're in a new market, you now know that it's quite possible that you might have a curve
that doesn't look like this but actually is flat for a long period of time.